in my art  i always try to find out  who is behind the mountains  that's very not about death  this natural landscape for me is uh  is life  that valley is magic  [Music]  people have lying that's human  never cross the line  in the art you have to cross the line  you must make the new line  the artist always fighting the  traditional  always best artists like that  i'm buddhist but my art  not the buddhist art but buddhists  change my mind change how  to see the life how to see the  test how to see the reborn  it changes the mind  painting is like your partner like  your eyeshadow your lover like that  [Music]  life is a cycle ribbon  test ribbon that's reborn always the  circle is a different life different  life different life  this is a universal  in my life in your life we not only  the first time talk or you interview me  is many times many times  we met together  you